what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so I took a poll with you guys on the
community tab of my YouTube channel
those of you guys who don't know there's
a community tab with my main channel I
can post different things make you guys
aware of stuff I can take polls we run
basically say what story should we do
next or something like that you guys can
vote on it it allows you guys to be more
interactive with the direction of the
channel which is kind of a good idea but
one of the questions I'd asked is should
we discuss how dr. Manhattan has
possibly created the entirety of the DC
universe and the response to this was
for the most part a resounding yes
everybody basically wanted to hear about
this idea that's been floating around
out there now this is not my theory I
did not think this up instead I came
across it I don't even know where to
rigea native from it most likely
originated on reddit but it may very
well be that you know some other website
thought it up and they've published it I
saw an article on movie pilot but it is
still a pretty cool theory and it is
still a pretty good idea but in order to
make this easy and simple to understand
really for the non comic reader or those
who are just now getting into DC more so
for the veteran readers we're basically
going to take this as a timeline we're
gonna say here's how things have rigidly
happened here's how new 52 is involved
and here's how dr. Manhattan seems to be
involved so starting with the original
timeline we can basically say that at
the beginning of all things there was
basically the Big Bang now this Big Bang
is exactly what you think it is it's
just an explosion of life in the DC
Universe and it wasn't like everything
came into existence all at once it was
really more of an event that was like a
prime mover in the sense that it just
sort of started life in motion so that
planets would begin to form stars would
begin to form solar systems would start
to take shape life would begin to form
on different planets and that was really
about it now more often than not this
basically Big Bang concept is
represented in DC Comics by a giant hand
kind of rising out of nothingness and
giving birth to all things but because
of the fact that we need a name for this
universe that's been formed and so that
we basically stay in line with you know
continuity so that when you guys do
research you don't feel thrown off we're
gonna call this timeline new earth now
in this new earth universe it's
basically all the classic DC stories
that you're familiar with and all the
history that goes into it as this
universe began to form as life began to
emerge some of the first beings to gain
into intelligence we're like the
Malthusians who are basically beings on
mountains they they basically achieve a
higher state of enlightenment they
learned about the emotional spectrum and
all
to mately they formed the Green Lantern
Corps now of course this Green Lantern
Corps serve the purpose of just policing
the universe more or less but while that
was going on he also had races like
Kryptonians coming into existence
Earthlings coming into existence and so
as time began to pass all the superhero
stories from before 2011 that you're
familiar with began to take place
Superman died at the hands of doomsday
Batman had his back broken by Bane all
those stories began to intertwine and
began to take form and wrap into that
stuff now what this does is it leads
into something called flashpoint and
this was basically a story whereby Barry
Allen was sitting at home one day
presumably and asked a question what
would happen if he went back in time and
he kept his mom from dawn because as we
know with the flash mythos a cornerstone
of his origin is that his mother died
when he was young and basically she was
killed by the reverse-flash but the
whole idea was that Barry Allen went
back in time and saved his mom's life
what this did is it wiped away all the
history and the new earth timeline all
that was gone Superman never died by the
hands of doomsday Batman never had his
back broken by Bane all that stuff was
gone in its place we got something
called the flashpoint universe and in
the flashpoint universe things were
starkly different it was largely
confined to earth and in this new
universe Superman never landed in Kansas
and was you know basically adopted by
the Kent's instead when he landed on
earth he was immediately taken by the
government and basically kept
underground and just bombarded with red
Sun radiation so his powers would never
emerge in this universe Bruce Wayne was
killed instead of his parents and the
result is that Thomas Wayne became
Batman and Martha Wayne became the Joker
in this universe Aquaman and Wonder
Woman went to war against one another so
as the Amazons versus the Atlanteans it
was a very dark and it was a very very
twisted universe with Barry Allen
realizing everything that had gone on
and after meeting the reverse-flash and
being told he was the one that caused
all this Barry Allen went back in time
again and basically allowed his mom to
die the hope of Barry Allen was that the
new earth time line would come back
instead what happened is we ended up
getting a new universe that was formed
basically a universe that was different
from the flashpoint universe and the new
earth universe what this was called was
earth Prime in this earth Prime
universe it's all the DC stories you've
been reading that DC's published since
2011 otherwise known as the new 52 and
the whole idea was that in this new
earth prime universe heroes had only
been around for about five years they
hadn't been around that long
they were basically brand new but
because of the actions of Barry Allen
everybody was basically starting fresh
nobody remember the new earth timeline
because as far as this was concerned it
never existed and so what this did is it
basically allowed DC to go forward and
basically tell new origin stories of
different things like that now with
regards to dr. Manhattan what they're
basically doing is they're going all the
way back to this new earth timeline the
one that was there originally and
basically saying that has always been
there the entire time it's never changed
it's always been the same that
essentially what happened was when barry
allen went back in time and you know
saved his mom's life and the flashpoint
universe replaced the new earth universe
and then he went back a second time and
let his mom die in reality the new earth
timeline did come back the reason why we
never realized that happened is because
dr. Manhattan stepped in and wiped it
off from everybody's minds he basically
stripped ten years away from everybody's
life and so under normal circumstances
if dr. Manhattan hadn't stepped in for
example then everybody would have
remembered everything everything would
have gone back to the way that it was
and there would have been no change
whatsoever stories would have just
continued on and that would have been it
but because of the actions of dr.
Manhattan nobody remembers that which is
why it's never been referenced that
seems to be what's taking place with
regards to the DC Universe the other
half of this is it feeds in to what
basically happened at the end of the
Watchmen comic that at the end of that
story
dr. Manhattan basically left earth he
has found humanity to be too complicated
too convoluted and two contradictory
and just walked away said he was
essentially tired of it basically
speculated the idea they'd go to some
other galaxy or go to some other place
and just make life the implication of
what's going on and the on running
theory is that the giant hand that we
saw reaching out of virtual nothingness
in order to create the new earth
universe in DC was the hand of dr.
Manhattan dr. Manhattan created the
entirety of the DC universe what that
means is he's been watching the entire
time dr. Manhattan was watching when the
Green Lantern's were first formed by the
guardians of the universe when Superman
was killed
by doomsday when Batman's back was
broken by paint he was watching all
these events unfold for whatever reason
that has not been explained yet when
Barry Allen went back in time saved his
mom's life then went back again and let
her die instead of allowing this new
earth time line to return the new earth
time line that dr. Manhattan created he
stepped in and he modified everybody's
memories so that as far as they're
concerned
no one's aware of this this previous
universe now they're basically becoming
aware of it they're basically learning
that they've been living in the
quote-unquote new earth timeline ever
since that everything is basically the
same as it always was they're slowly
coming to that realization now because
of what we saw in DC universe rebirth
number one with a lot of these higher
echelon characters you know Pandora
different characters like that who we
haven't really talked about too much but
with those characters basically being
obliterated in their entirety the
indication seems to be that within that
10-year window that dr. Manhattan
removed from the minds of all the
superheroes they most likely learned of
his existence they most likely realized
he was there and if they did then the
only alternative for him to basically
keep his existence hidden without wiping
everything out and starting all over
again is to wipe their memories of him
from the minds of everybody on earth
that's the theory that's going on the
dr. Manhattan created the DC Universe
dr. Manhattan set the DC Universe in
motion when the flashpoint event
happened and people basically learned of
dr. Manhattan's existence he wiped all
knowledge of his existence from the
minds of the Earth's heroes the side
effect is that they basically believed
they were starting their lives for the
very first time in reality they weren't
they're living the same life they always
have it's almost like they have amnesia
and so that's the nature of what's going
on in DC rebirth right now at least
that's the theory that's happening at
the moment but again there's a lot of
unanswered questions here it's not a
fully fleshed out theory it is a little
bit confusing and a bit convoluted just
because of the fact that there are so
many questions that we have that we
don't have answers to yet but at the
very least it's pretty cool but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain and make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob pork you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you